24 ans après le meurtre de stefan
dietrich qui pouvait encore espérer un
procès est le début d'une vérité pour la
famille et les amis du jeune homme
c'est la fin d'une très longue attente
le 5 juillet 1994 stéphane dietrich
étudiant brillant est découvert
assassiné dans un bois près de belfort
le corps transpercé de 11 coups de
couteau
très vite son meilleur ami et placé en
garde à vue il est le dernier à l'avoir
vu vivant mais il nie toute implication
dès lors le dossier s'enlise jusqu'au
non lieu prononcé en 2002 à la stupeur
générale
mon frère a été tué un endroit son corps
était transporté en sait toujours pas à
l'heure actuelle où ils étaient tués
on n'a toujours pas retrouvé l'armé du
crime donc ça je dirais c'est aussi
simple que le cluedo
il faut que des gens des professionnels
se mettent à la tâche le frère de
stéphane dietrich ne lâche rien il crée
une association et médiatise la faire
c'est en 2013 que le dossier connaît un
rebondissement inattendu deux anciens
lycéens identifie dans une émission
l'ami de stéphane comme le surveillant
qui leur avait proposé de l'argent pour
commettre un crime
une déposition capitales qui auraient
poussé l'homme aux aveux après des
années de faux semblants il va nous
expliquer qu'il entretenait une relation
passionnelle et homosexuels avec la
victime que cette relation était
relativement
avec une personnalité du mis en cause
qui est quand même très très complexes
et que ne supportant plus cette relation
il avait effectivement tué son meilleur
ami christophe blain toujours présumé
innocent est aujourd'hui âgé de 49 ans
il était conseiller en patrimoine dans
le var et avait refait sa vie
on savait déjà à la base qu il disait
des mensonges et souvent je lui ai
demandé avant l'enterrement de mon frère
de faire avec lui
le parcours de ce qu'ils avaient fait en
voiture jamais elle a pu le faire
jamais la faille inculpé de meurtre avec
préméditation et incarcéré christophe
blain devra s'expliquer cette semaine
sur les raisons de son geste
la dernière pièce du puzzle celle que la
famille de stéphane dietrich attend
depuis 24 ans